this one's funny this is from Omar is a
garbage to pay off tonight's tickets in
multiple
payments trying to spread that [__]
around come talk to me next month will
you waiting on a few things to shake out
gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus we
play a little AIG with the crowd shows
are selling out and you can get your
tickets at rug garbage.com see it
[Music]
a welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is Ru garbage oh yeah it's
that little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy or if they're just a
big old whole piece of trash garbage I'm
your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toies in a new edition she's upstairs
putting the Halloween decorations up
okay stole the good ones this year good
for her went over to the rich
neighborhood got the goods baby okay all
right my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he's International businessman
and my best pal in the whole wide world
and I love him give it up for KJ it's
Kevin James Ryan everybody what's up
gang thanks uh thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate VI
subscribe on iTunes Video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
true cooking over there and obviously
the greatest website of all time oh yeah
www.patreon.com
garbage don't make me freaking say it
again it's a good time over there uhhuh
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
McMullen everybody what up dude what up
pal I'm another I'm excited we got a
nice nice person thing with pulled up
with a crew this one this R entour
coming in Industry I like it and it
feels like it might be a little Touch of
Class she seems like a class broad this
one gang we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time she's a very
funny very successful standup comedian
actor and podcaster and you might have
seen her in but not limited to we got
bride to be Zoe Ever After marry xas
these are terrible If Loving You Is
Wrong absolutely not family the Trap
love hard bone marry Berry Ladies Night
Live Watch What Happens Live bad dates
the Today's Show she has an amazing
podcast absolutely not she's on tour
right now but the reason she's here she
just dropped her debut Netflix special
that you got to check out son I never
had give it up for Heather mcmah and
everybody thank you hey buddy hey buddy
did y'all just print out my IMDb because
he handwrites it so just so you know the
first like 10 things where I always play
like the [__] white girl on every bet
show show yeah so I was always like the
token white girlfriend that every person
on every show hated so I know I
recognized you yeah that's that's what
those credits are that's got paid a rent
baby you know what I'm saying exactly
exactly congrats on the special hey
thank you little Netflix cash coming in
like to see it yeah shaking my tits for
cash on the
Netflix hey someone's got to do it
someone's got to do it I'll tell you
what I'll tell you what yeah give us
back story where you from give us the
origin story You' had in I I love it I'm
from hotlanta there you go born and
raised hotlanta my mom's from Boston my
dad was a good Southern Man um went to
school at the University of Mississippi
hotti totty so a Southern bell Southern
bell with like some Yankee Roots how did
your parents link up bu um they actually
met at uh in baggage claim at Miami
International Airport Jesus Christ
that's a Coke deal going wrong no
literally my dad was selling Coke my dad
was 23 my mom shut up are you serious
dad oh we're in it ladies and Gentlemen
let's go they both worked for Eastern
Airlines at the time but my dad was like
young selling Coke when he wasn't a
baggage service guy so no [__] yeah yeah
um and my mom's 11 years older than my
father since passed but was 11 years
older than myate Dad so my mom was like
an original cougar that's an OG cougar
right there yeah holy [__] and how did
they settle in Atlanta uh my dad was
from Atlanta okay so literally they had
my sister who's 3 years older than me
and my mom was like we can't do this we
can't be living in literally like the
world of cocaine we got to get out here
and so they moved to Atlanta and then
they had me and yeah wow what your what
your pop do why you were why you guys
were growing up was he still working for
the airline no no no so he basically he
was very successful in the mortgage
business um he had his own like a
mortgage technology software company and
then when he sold that he uh uh he was
like in real estate and [__] like that
couple of bucks growing up couple of
bucks well we had it was it was uh real
broke and then not broke at all and I it
was nice you know what I mean it was it
nice eighth grade things got real nice
it's a good age I like it that's when
you're aware too you you know it yeah we
moved out like a shitty neighborhood and
we moved next to our golf we joined a
golf club we we move next to the golf
club there you go start getting name
brand cereals real poptarts oh yeah my
mom said that there was a day when we
were in the grocery store and I was
little and I I said something like Mom
we can't get the ice cream because we
don't have a coupon and that's the day
my mom went home and was like Kyle let's
figure out this [__] business plan
sell that company yeah this is he
started his business in the basement and
then the wild thing is now my office is
in that basement like I took over my
dad's office and yeah my husband and I
moved into my childhood home so now I
run my Empire from the basement what'
you do with your mom she's there she's
with us yeah someone's got to cut the
grass exactly you gave her a boot you
got her in retirement home no no no
Robin is with us um she still puts [__]
in a basket like at the bottom of the
stairs like I am like 13 again so to
take it upstairs yeah to take it
upstairs a real mom move real mom move
walk by once or twice and didn't take it
upstairs you got an earful you walked
right by it you could have brought it
upstairs yeah but she'll put stuff like
you know uh W2s 1099s all that kind of
[__] in the basket and like I'll miss
major like financial documents tax
returns and all that [__] and I don't
get it I put in your basket I'm like
well now I'm getting audit in so thanks
Mom that's all right so was that the
house you grew up in um yeah from like
eighth grade on ni so when my dad died
my mom was basically like I was living
in New York i' had been in LA and then I
was living in New York with my husband
then the pandemic hit and my mom was
going to sell the house we were like
just perfect timing my mom said you know
come down we escaped the city and then
she was like you know do you all want
the house and we were like yeah so we're
actively buying the house from her yeah
so we're give you a deal she no no [__]
raed over the co my mom is Italian and
Irish from the North End in Boston she
literally called me today she had to
ship something up to New York cuz I'm
you know running around she's like so
you going to bend me the $300 I'm like
I'll be home in 3 days need that cash
though she is so Boston Robin it'll be
3:30 when you get there got that v on it
no [__] yeah that's all right yeah what
uh okay what was uh what was the grocery
store growing up oh we are big Publix
people sh out the Publix compan you know
have you ever had a pub sub no I've
heard good things though we've heard
from the listeners yeah okay a pub sub
will change your life okay you guys are
are from Pennsylvania so what do you
call it a hogy hog a Hogie yeah hugy
downtown you get your Hogie yeah enough
out of you yeah yeah I know um so yeah
we get a pub sub Pub and our sandwiches
are like you know you get a full
basically foot long and you put chicken
tenders that are tossed in Buffalo sauce
and with like two sides of ranch and
pepper jack cheese that's a sub sandwich
to me you know what I mean I like it my
kind of gu type two diabetes immediately
yeah let's go what were you living in
before you moved to the house in e8th
grade was it an apartment a house no no
we were living in a house but it was you
know we moved to a really kind of bougie
suburb yeah but it was good I mean my
dad you know know he worked his ass off
and then and then we popped off so yeah
did your mom work at all well so my mom
was 40 when she had me so my mom had
worked in the airline biz for like 40
years so by the time she had me she was
like stayed home with the kids what was
she a flight attendant no she worked in
um everything other than being on the
airplanes yeah gate agent admin type got
yeah no she was literally like if you
lost your luggage she's running all
those Department Robin's going to track
it down and get it yeah yeah Robin's
going to track it down Eastern Airlines
too that's old school old school yeah H
did you guys get to fly for free no
because Eastern Airlines was defunct by
the time I came around and fun fun fact
my grandfather you can Google him
Captain Jack McMahon was the chief pilot
for Delta for a long time what a name
there you go Jack McMahon he sa that's a
guy you want flying a plane oh yeah he
saved an airplane he won the dallion
safety award because he saved an
airplane that they that was going to
crash that had a major mechanical error
and so my dad he thought he would you
know he he like dropped out of Georgia
tag because he was you know uh doing
drugs and [__] so he thought he'd be
able to get a job at Delta and they were
like no we're not going to hire you
because they used to have a nepotism
Clause so then that's why my dad went
down to Miami to like go find himself
and work at Easter and then he found a
hot red head who was 11 years older than
him my mother yeah there you go yeah so
I come a long I come from a long line of
aviators but Captain Jack that's right
Captain Jack what do you got on Captain
Jack listen to how badass this is wait
are you kidding me you got it yeah the
saving of flight
1080 BR that's right go G yeah I'm
garbage
am not a reggae
concert Dam what go ahead on Delta's
flight 1080 leaving San Diego this is on
October 8th
1978 uh so everyone on the plane is
smoking unfiltered cigarettes for sure
on Delta's flight 1080 leaving San Diego
the passengers were lucky enough to have
Jack McMahon at at the controls [__] I'm
shoving up here this story [__]
awesome isn't that crazy yeah the man H
so growing up we were cuz my talk about
a cowboy talk about no he was a cowboy
too so he grew up in Fort Worth so his
background was he was a famous uh bull
bucking bull rider and then he went and
served in the Air Force and the Army and
then he became uh became a pilot at at
Delta was he a pilot in the in the
service yes he was yeah that's where he
learned how to fly yeah this guy pisses
whiskey a man dude yeah no a real man my
Papa Jack was like the coolest guy in
the world and so my dad learned how to
fly an airplane before he ever learned
how to drive a car so my dad soloed his
first flight at like 13 which was like
highly illegal to do so we grew up like
you know people bought fancy cars we had
a little twin engine Cessna and that's
just what you did like on the weekends
my dad would be like we getting this
tiny little four seater we had a little
duffel bag and we would just go to
Hilton Head that's what we would do holy
and this tiny little airpl sick yeah
three keys in the back yeah no literally
literally probably and my dad spoke
fluent Spanish so it it it's all making
sense man this guy moves way yeah rest
in peace I love it dude Captain Jack
that's great that's the guy you want man
I got on a a flight one time and the
pilot got on you and an acoustic
guitar we're going down yeah that's who
you want man that's awesome yeah all
right so you went to Publix yeah I went
to Publix how was the schooling grades
good um I was never very Scholastic but
I'm a politician I was student body
president you know what I mean that's a
real not smart thing I'm Scholastic yeah
I'm not throw out big I like how you you
run for office start changing the grade
system absolutely everything's on a
curve um yeah I was uh school was not my
strongest but I went to the same school
from kindergarten through 12th grade so
I knew how to like run the show you know
what I mean public private school
private school private school private
school Catholic uh wors Church of Christ
okay yeah yeah which is old school yeah
old school uh we are not Church of
Christ but we're I'm like a
non-denominational Christian I'm
basically Methodist you know what I mean
and people get very upset they're like
pick one I'm like I'm chill you know I
mean you're hanging out hanging out for
Jesus I'm hanging out for Jesus like
everybody chill any sports growing up
yeah I played soccer and I played golf
golfer yeah and then I was a cheerleader
I was a big golfer go huh golf you still
golf now I still golf now I wish I could
play more than I do my husband gets the
luxury of uh playing golf every week um
but yeah I was a compe you're on a golf
course technically in house we literally
live next door to our golf course but he
you know has more time on his hands so
he gets to enjoy that yeah but I played
golf competitively growing up and I'm a
big golf nerd and like a big fan love
that b yeah kind of clubs you got um
Titus they ain't they ain't trashy I
know I got I got a mix I like my
callaways and then I got Titus I I mix
it up I just got a set of callaways nice
hone how you feel uh I only hit them
once and I was drunk so yeah yeah there
you go there you go I'll tell you in a
couple months yeah what did you major in
at uh Mississippi uh theater theater
Arts at the University of Mississippi
okay yeah I'm I'm a classically trained
actor very nice did you do any
sororities down there hell yeah shout
out to Delta
gamma in the Buns yeah so my sity was
founded at the University of Mississippi
so it was like hard yeah it was the be
it was the best people find out I was an
a sority I mean obviously like I've got
the blonde curly hair like I look like a
sority girl but it was great it was like
the best for years of my life people had
bad uh Greek experiences I feel really
sorry for them but I had a [__] blast
yeah I loved it I like it notice the ice
on the finger I don't caught that thank
you sh to the hubby very put together
yeah got nice blouse on Good Nails don't
think I didn't catch the Manny on way
Ferrari red don't you worry spr spraying
your wrist carrying that thing around
listen I I I deserve this I have been I
do no we're we celebrated here we
celebrated shout out to Meer my jeweler
at H&H jewelry and the diamond they make
bagels what are you talking about they
do uh but my in-laws hate me so I I
deserve this nice rank you know what I
mean all right little beef with the in I
respect that shabby who would uh who
would babysit you growing up oh uh did
you have family around you no we didn't
have a lot of family around us so no it
was just a it was a random mixed bag
whoever was available yeah yeah I didn't
grow up with like that one babysitter
like old Susan you know what I mean got
no it was like young fun fun gals in the
hood okay all right what was the pet
situation growing up oh okay well I'm
going to get [__] roasted for this
big cat rescuer okay so we had a lot of
cats growing up okay um you can hear the
Southern Southern accent a lot of cats
growing up yeah we just had a lot of
loose felines in the yard um actually
super funny before we like we live on
the river in in Atlanta and it's super
funny uh this house is sounding worse
there's a bunch of cats we're on a river
no no no the river's nice the chatah
huchi is real nice
chii but my dad was smoking a the C way
down on the chattahi we my dad was
smoking a cigarette on the porch one day
and he literally comes comes in and he
just goes Kitty's gone hot got him and
I'm like what do you mean he's like the
kitty is gone a hot got him hot came
down when my dad was smoking just took
the cat so after that we we had less
cats and now I have two French Bulldogs
all right that's pretty cool mom what
are the names of the dogs uh rigoton
canoli gandley Daniels and then that's a
good time hold on a second that's back
down he gave the dog a middle name two
mdle I think it's got a confirmation
name too it does it has a confirmation
name yeah rigoton canoli gandal Daniels
and then my daughter's name is macaroni
lemon Ferrari Daniels okay yeah very
Italian all right yeah okay I don't know
if it's Italian it's trash it ain't
[__] the Kennedy ain't doing that
what do you call the dogs dayto day Rigs
and Mac Rigs and oh that's fun Rigs and
Max is good yeah they sound like two
cops like a like a a yeah 100% that's an
animated series right there let's go you
got the net children's book at
least yeah little French bulldog with a
gun under its arm
godamn thing I ever heard of Hawaiian
shirt this is rice itself R is getting
too old for this [__] for sure we got to
cut all this yeah what about the
vacations as a kid where would you guys
go other than Hilton Head oh well we
would crush Hilton Head and then um we
would we [__] it up anybody knows Hilton
Head shout out to Sea Pines in the
alligator Grill um the alligator Grill
and then we became those people who went
to the Turks and caos so we were going
to the islands when no like when it was
Limestone Road there there cuz my dad
could fly us down so we went down there
and we would go be very adventurous and
we're going to the Turks now everybody
goes to the Turks you guys he would fly
you down there in the plane yeah holy
[__] he upgraded later we ended up
getting a King Air but we never had like
a jet but we had a King Air which was in
incredible and so my dad would fly us
down we' go to the Turks holy [__] I
don't think we ever had anybody that
flew themselves on vacation we
definitely haven't had anybody that had
a plane I got to look uping yeah give
get some eyes on that was it a propeller
plane y oh yeah that thing's sick it
could it could seat about seven people
that's drug Runner all day yep and if
you knew my daddy's like the best guy in
the world like just the cutest like just
the best but yeah we would fly around
the coolest thing was when I was when I
was in college that was my one like hard
Flex you have to realize when you go to
the University of Mississippi there is
so much money there my dad it's like
it's like old it's like Southern royalty
yeah my dad pulls up for a a game and
he's like flying himself into the Oxford
Airport so he pulls up and it's just
Gulf Stream after Gulf Stream and my dad
gets out and he goes godamn it I'm the
poorest guy here what the [__] poor guy
at the private Airport's all right
though yeah he was like this is insane
so my dad would pick up like some myself
and my sority sisters and he'd like fly
us you know to lunch and [__] around
town dude that's awesome yeah he was the
best that's Cowboy [__] Cowboy [__]
that's classy yeah right holy [__] um
how about the lunches growing up would
you pack a lunch would you yeah we
packed a lunch my mom was like organic
and Gourmet before it was a thing
because she yeah yeah we these mcmahons
are ahead of the here yeah they really
are yeah my mom was on the she was on
this show Master Chef for a hot season
my mom's an incredible Chef what the
[__] who are you your dad flies Jets and
your mom's a Master Chef and your
grandfather is the coolest guy in the
world wait she was on Master Chef like
Master Chef yeah but she was just on the
first season she was a contestant but my
mom's an incredible Chef so she never
let us grow up like eating the shitty
lunch you know we like if if you brought
a Lunchable to home my mom would like
set it on fire she's like how dare you
but she's also Italian so she's like she
got that firecracker in her would she
whip it up on Sundays make a nice Sunday
Sunday dinner oh yeah we would do a
Sunday or we go a Longhorn Steak House
you know what I mean here we go both
sides of both sides of the coin with
this one I know I know but again we
would take our private jet yeah but we
also love the longhorn of Flo's filet
yeah oh uhhuh wow that really is the
duality of uh of a human right there
Crazy K let's talk about liquid IV shout
out to liquid IIs baby shout out to all
the athletes out there or the booze bags
or the drunk shout out to you that's
right or if you're just not feeling well
do yourself a favor get a liquid IV in
it's absolutely fantastic stay hydrated
when Uncle hanky was real sick last
winter what did I use I use Liquid IV
got me through it I like the oo
pineapple is what I like with three
times the electrolytes got a leading
sports drinks plus eight vitamins and
nutrients for everyday Wellness through
yourself a favor get some liquid IV yeah
baby liquid IV is now available in three
sugar-free flavors we got white peach
green grape and lemon lime with no
artificial sweeteners in it you get the
amazing flavor without that gross bitter
aftertaste it's gluten-free dairy free
soy free has no GMOs liquid IV is
amazing addition to your hydration
routine we take it on a row with us
every day we wake up in the Airbnb shake
it up throw it back onto the onto the
next one baby do grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier sugarfree in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20%
off when you go to liquid i.com and use
code garbage at checkout that's 20% off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration today using promo code garbage
at liquid i.com do it gang yeah kid
let's talk about manscape let's talk
about cleaning your sack up yeah gang
it's football season it's basketball
season it's baseball season you know
what else it is keep your nuts clean
season yeah baby shave off your bird
will you and we're talking about the
fifth generation performance package
featuring an allnew lawn mower
5.0 Ultra what are we doing here keeping
fresh debone K puts I tell that the
other day when you're going you down
there when you're going for a close
shave do yourself a favor when you're
going below the belt do the use the best
of the best and that's the lawn mower
5.0 Ultra with the performance package
and manscaped yeah baby uh they've been
a supporter for of our for years I take
it you got to tr you know your your
little dingleberry your little ball your
twig berries maybe get on your there and
a grle zip it up zip it out then I then
I touch up my beard touch up the old
mustache that's your After
Shave nut sack by Kippy that's raunda
cheese by Kippy uh get 20% off in free
shipping with the code garbage
manscape.com that's 20% off and free
shipping with code garbage manscape.com
do it gang yeah my mom came from
literally nothing and so it's so funny
when she you know and she lives a very
comfortable life now but is still so
cheap on some [__] it's great that she
keeps me very humble when do you got her
in the house does she get to keep her
room or you guys took the master bedro
she's in the primary she's in the master
and then we built like we took my old
room and like blew out a closet and made
a a bigger space but we're on the same
floor so just so you know I'm in my
first year marriage on the same floor
with my mother with your mother yeah and
my mom's in your room that you grew up
in in my room that I grew up in yeah and
and a bunch of my friends like oh this's
a t party thing that's so sweet like
you're taking care of your mom like
first of all my mom doesn't look a day
of her 40 she is 75 she is hot she is
like she doesn't need to be taken care
of but she loves having us around and my
husband gets treated like a king and I'm
chop Li you know what I mean so your mom
doing the laundry and stuff uh no no I
mean she will she's very helpful but no
I'm not asking her to do that okay yeah
all right yeah um you got the place
decorator right now for uh for Halloween
or the fall or anything like that say
that one more time do you decorate the
house for the fall or Hall well here's a
deal here's a deal I love a themed party
I I knew that about you oh yeah I mean I
was a sorty girl you kidding me you give
me any theme I I I got you um however my
dad died at Christmas so we don't put up
[__] at Christmas we go to the Turks and
Kos you know what I mean pretty good
yeah but no we keep it nice we keep it
real nice nice manicured lawn it's it's
nice do you have a place down in Turks
and Kos that you guys like to always go
we do shout out to weara weara Resorts
and Villas she just got a free weekend
right there well we we own the place so
yeah yeah no um my my dad helped for a
second oh your dad helped develop it
yeah my dad my dad was yeah my dad was
was one of the developers down there but
we still own a unit there so that's our
that's our happy place oh really yeah
the tury Kos a villa you got a villa
down there no we don't have a villa
that's my that's on the vision board I'd
like to eventually buy a villa but no we
just have a a one-bedroom there and we
go down and have a v that's not a time
share right no not a time share no no no
no no you can just individually only
classy this a classy lady talking about
a time share right now how dare you
think that I would have a time share
right now you want you you go over to
you hop on a plane you can go down there
you let yourself right in yeah well I
mean that's how owning a property works
it's managed by tomorrow but like you
know we rent it out to people and so it
just run like a hotel and then if we
want to block it off but usually we go
down there we let keep that rented and
then I'll you know uh wheel and deal get
aill how long do you stay down there
when you get on there for Christmas um
we go for a week go for the week yeah
yeah man that's okay man you're you're a
boss this is you're my might be my
favorite person listen I'll let you guys
go down there whenever I love sharing
this I like you guys I absolutely come
down let's do it I mean that I'm not
bullshitting like come down to the we'll
be there next week okay great great good
luck trying to get us
out okay what was your first job growing
up um well of course I did like the
babysitting and the nannying and all
that stuff but I have worked every
Hospitality restaurant job I've been a
Hostess I've been a waiter I mean when I
lived in New York as soon as I graduate
college I worked at Stout which is that
giant Irish sports bar I went on a
horrible first date there one time yeah
oh of course you did and I probably
waited on you and it was it was a
nightmare but I that was I worked every
restaurant job you can imagine okay yeah
huh and then I worked in when I moved to
LA I worked for the F like the real
popular spin gym Soul cycle that's when
my soul left my body because I had to
wait on [__] celebrities all day and
they were a nightmare and then I did odd
jobs for like celebrities and stuff like
that wait what did you do with soul
psycle were you an instructor no I
worked the front desk I literally was
like the first chain of commands you'd
come in and I I all these celebrities
would like you know I'm like they they
would get my personal number put in
their phone they' text me like can you
get me off the wait list and if you were
nice to me and de de if you brought me
like a Chipotle gift card if you were
nice to me then I bribe I
fully 100% worked the [__] system I
respect it yeah yeah and now I get to do
like projects with some of these people
that I used to work on or I'll see them
out and about in like industry [__] and
I'm just like you were a piece of [__]
you know what I mean love that yeah
listen we're big on holding grudges
around here absolutely are you allowed
to eat in your room as a kid uh yes but
I would get screamed at you know what I
mean I would sneak it I was also a very
chubby child so I had a lot of like you
know hot Che in the closet and [__] like
that got yeah yeah yeah my mom's thin my
sister's thin and I took after my dad
sugar cereal when you were a kid were
you allowed to have that in the house um
okay what was your go-to my go well my
go-to is golden grams but my mom would
try and feed us some all natural like
granola with the skin milk situation I
had an almond mom if you know what an
almond mom is it's like a mom when
you're hungry she's like suck on an
almond oh yeah have three almonds it's
like lady I'm talking about aie make
with the p
yeah yeah uh but my mom would make us
like you know I had the house set after
the movies when you were in like Junior
High people came over cuz my mom would
make chicken picata like on on the spot
she fed us people wanted to come over to
my house to hang out with my parents cuz
they were cool and they fed you well it
wasn't I had to go to everybody else's
house for like cheddar check mix and
like cool range Doritos any sodas in the
house growing up yeah my dad was
addicted to uh caffeine-free Diet Coke I
was like the brown one the gold the gold
Brown can yes were they cans or two lers
cans yeah oh yeah he had a crisp can I
mean my dad would literally he wasn't a
big drinker he would pack when he would
fly he'd pack like a soft-sided like
Yeti cooler with like 45 caffeine free
Diet Cokes it is 100% flying a plane man
can have whatever the hell he wants
exactly did you guys have a garage
fridge at the house growing up uh yes
and still do absolutely what what's in
there there oh you know like the frozen
pizzas also like my mom always had like
lamb like my mom will cook a lamb chop
at like if I come home from tour at like
2 a.m. I'm like Mom can I have a chop
she's you know a lot of can I have L
chops that's the classiest [__] I ever
had best lamb chops I bet your mom does
chops right yeah she does chops right
yeah with marala mushrooms but here's
the thing go to Costco they have the
best lamb chops in a great deal go to
Costco to get your chops I got you I see
I mean what are you 12 pounds of chops
yeah um all right you mentioned frozen
pizza what kind of frozen pizza you
banging with I mean back in the day
though it was only Douro you know what I
mean you didn't have I mean we were
Atlant that's that's that's what we we
dealt with what are you banging with now
oh God you know it's probably some like
gluten-free [__] because or
something flower power yeah flow
big hly Power guy how do you feel about
the stoer French bread pizza oh [__] me
up
yeah that's the right an yeah [__] me up
get up that plane let's go to France and
get some baby
absolutely um you guys ever been kicked
out of a restaurant as a family um no we
haven't well we got close to we were
actually in Charleston South Carolina
and this shout out to Charleston shout
out to Charleston and this woman came up
and was trying to do a bit like with my
mom cuz my mom has a thick Bostonian
accent oh they don't like that no and my
mom and my mom thinks she's a Southern
bell cuz she's lived in Atlanta for like
you know forever but my mom's like
packing the cat and have it yet so she
sits at her country club and is like I'm
so Southern what are you talking about
you're like no you're not Robin Robin
get a grip okay but we were the people
that people got annoyed at a restaurant
cuz we were really loud and I this is
like one tender memory like I had fun
with my family it just we we called
ourselves a nuclear family it's like my
dad my mom my sister and I we would go
to restaurants and laugh so hard and
like has each other and have the best
time so people got annoyed they were
always telling us to be quiet at the
Country Club but we had a really good
time I respect it though you're having a
good time you guys are like Rodney
danger yeah no literally yeah I get no
respect oh man what uh what kind of car
you whipping around in now if you don't
mind me asking oh yeah I got a Q5 white
leased Audi I'm new money personally new
money so I'm leasing it through the
business as my financial adviser told me
to do I still have my 2015 Jetta though
that's what my husband's driving I love
that J there you go I love it white Audi
a white Audi yeah that's can I be honest
with you that's a right of passage when
you make a little money and you're a
southern white woman you get either a
white Lexus a white Mercedes or a white
Audi that or you're in the Russian mafia
absolutely yeah do you eat in the car
sorry do you eat in the car hell yeah
Chick-fil-A 24/7 yeah go to The Waffle
House pick up a pean waffle and just eat
it in my car and you know
cry yes absolutely you can eat in the
car uh okay what kind of air freshener
you got in there no air fresh I got to
be honest with you they give me a
headache a horrible headache you know I
just let the windows you know just some
fresh Georgia Air you wash in the car on
the r you get a detailed you get the
inside done my husband is very he does
that for me okay yeah yeah yeah so
you're washing the car in the driveway
no no oh no no no Absolut not goes and
get that HOA would never let us do that
in the driveway no no no no you don't do
chores in public no no no who's cutting
the grass you guys cut it you got a oh
no we got we got a lawn we got a lawn
Team all right a whole team yeah we got
on team okay I tell you man I don't
really know here okay I do I don't know
there's a I like this there's dirt under
their fingernails for sure what was your
first concert you went to Spice Girls
that's of the time that's okay it was it
was the fourth grade and uh my dad took
me with all my girlfriends and it was
like the coolest did he fly anywhere no
it was just in Atlanta it was in Moscow
buddy yeah yeah it was in Moscow yeah
but he was a like a kid in a candy shop
cuz it was like him and all these hot
moms you know what I mean sure that's
pretty cool what about the poster
situation on the wall in the in the room
as kid who' you have um I had the Spice
Girls and I had like two gu I had Justin
Timberlake from insync I thought
everybody else was ugly I got to be
honest with you the back street boys and
inbody else was they were they were not
cute and any women who say like to JT
talking about if you look back now
looking back they were like they you
just thought they were all attractive
guys you look back now they were [__]
mutants the one was like 42 yeah shout
out to Joey Von shout out to Joey Fone
actually funny story I was on mushrooms
at um the cardi B concert before the
Super Bowl like a couple years ago Joey
fitton's brother was a videographer for
cardi B and was and literally all of a
sudden next thing you know I end up on
the Jumbotron this is my first time
doing mushrooms so I am just living [__]
you up he comes up to me afterwards he's
like by the way my wife's a big fan so I
just wanted to put you on the Jumbotron
all night I'm like I'm high as [__]
right now I'm losing my mind jaming me
up yeah shout out to Steve Steve Fone
Steve
Fone okay um you a peanut butter fan oh
huge what do you got at the house right
now what brand what are you rocking can
I be honest with you I have every Nut
Butter you can imagine okay I got I
really like Trader Joe's I'm a Trader
Joe's girl now I yeah that's where I
thrive okay are you like going and and
shopping yourself or do you do you get
an order no let me give you a little
ASMR I want to run my fingers across all
the different hummus dips I want to look
I get the the Trader Joe's frequent
flyer cuz I'm on the road so often that
when I'm home I really love to do like
like really hardcore domestic things
like the Costco that's why I know about
the chops I like to just go and shop and
peruse and then I'm home for two days
and I don't eat any of food like you
know like I mean I set my husband up
nice but okay I I get that so it's
crater Joe's brand peanut butter yeah I
like crunchy or creamy I I have both
they also have a Mixed Nut Butter that
is like super salty and it's delicious
yeah yeah yeah I love a hazelnut spread
I love it all and what are you putting
that on if you make a PB&J first of all
I assume the the jelly the jam is from
Trader Joe's as well yeah I like that or
I'll do something from Whole Foods you
know what I mean I get some sort of nice
uh nice I'll upgrade the jam but I
strawberry mixed berry oh I'll do it all
all poison Berry GOI Berry I don't give
a [__] multigrain bread what are we
using I'm really a big sourdough fan and
I know if you've never had a PB&J on a
sour dough it's delicious sourdough is
making a comeback like no other right
now yeah they're going to be the next
cauliflower I'm telling you but if you
ALS if you also have eczema and a a
little gluten intolerant you can you can
handle sour death yeah it's good for you
yeah okay have you ever own a Big Mouth
Billy Bass no this feels like a bit of a
layup have you ever ridden a mechanical
Bowl absolutely got one in the house
yeah right went to school in Mississippi
yeah well that was her thesis yeah
absolutely come on now don't insult me
of course I have uh have you ever named
a pet in a voicemail named a a pet in a
voicemail what do you mean hey you've
reached Heather andony no absolutely not
no H okay ever seen a UFO ABS yes lay it
on us mushrooms can I be honest with you
Steve Fone Steve Fone what's up in the
Turks and C Coast when you're out there
and it's quiet and you're looking at the
stars I have definitely seen some things
that I thought were you know not of this
world yeah and listen a lot of people in
aviation will tell you like my dad used
to see some [__] so so to my papa yeah
but you didn't really talk about my my
dad was a huge Jack ain't lying I'll
tell you that goddamn straight shooter
godam Aman hero yeah yeah right oh yeah
I believe in aliens full force how do
you feel about pineapple on Pizza can I
be honest with you it's
delicious you are a politician I like
that no it's delicious and you know what
I really love is to get a Hawaiian pizza
and then just a [__] ton of ranch and
then like a a Polynesian sauce from
Chick-fil-A mix it all together it's
delicious wait a minute you're using the
Chick-fil-A sauce on other things other
than Chick-fil-A items yes I'm from
Atlanta Georgia that's going in a file
okay great that ain't great that ain't
great that's a big one ordered stuff
Crust Pizza yeah that's what everybody
did I mean Papa John's or no it was
Pizza Hut stuff Crust Pizza back in the
day if it didn't almost choke you out
like if your crust wasn't like a
mozzarella stick then what were you
doing yeah if you had to choose between
what would be your the your chain
delivery pizza at the house now if you
had to do it oh now if I had to do it
Papa John's Domino's Pizza Hut uh I
would say I prefer a Domino's moment
because I like the thin crust it's like
very very like wafer crispy I'll give it
to you yeah but growing up Big Papa
John's family Papa down the South they
were they was big from down there right
yeah it's I think he's from St Louis but
the thing is again it's a sauce if
you're from the south you're very big in
E joh I think he's from St Louis I shout
out Papa John I think he's a horrible
guy appar I think he's a great guy I
don't think he's a great guy but loved
it growing up huh okay will you reuse to
go containers uh no absolutely not no
will you take leftovers home from a
restaurant I would but weird I don't
love leftovers but my everybody else in
my family loves a leftover I'm anti-
leftover it's been well documented but
yeah I think it's it's it creep so what
are we doing here what are we doing
already had it I'll go yeah I'll go get
more french fries or whatever I don't
need I don't need to take these home if
you go out to dinner are you picking up
the check most of the times every single
time yes now my mom now she's gotten
used to it I mean that's why when she
was like you know you owe me 300 do I'm
like Mom shut up you haven't paid for a
lunch in three years since I moved home
I don't want to hear it credit scores
good uh yes now it is and the irony of
it was when my dad died now it is now it
is my dad taught me about credit like
that was the one thing you learned about
and then when he died I you know I my
career was not where it was and I was
just like [__] this and I somehow got
you know a credit card and I I ruined my
credit but now it's back we're back baby
we're back baby uh if you do order
takeout you get takeout or delivered to
the house so you get an entree or
whatever will you plate that food or
will you eat it out of the takeout
container I'll tell you what
I love eating off real silverware in
Real China and we uh we went to I go to
Italy a lot okay Italy I go to Italy a
lot that's what I do I got married there
last year I was just there a couple
weeks married in Italy what town yeah uh
we got married in Florence very nice
very nice all the way from [__]
longhorn state C say that much sure is
my family is Sicilian my husband's
family is from all over in Italy and so
that's our happy place a lot of people
in South get lak houses we just spend
our money and go to Italy a couple times
a year but I said that because in Italy
you know they only eat off real silver
and real China and so after my wedding I
was like why the [__] am I eating off
this [__] so I make a real
cappuccino in the morning in the China
like why do you have your grandmother's
China if you're not going to eat or
drink off of it so I like nice plates
I'm that's what I like I like nice
plates okay an espresso you have an
espresso machine absolutely the shout
out to Breville yeah and William Sona
yeah some reason I just imagine your
China has Dale Earhart Jr that's what
I'm saying or it's stolen from somewhere
high class man she's got good tast does
you're refined you're a refined Southern
uh Southern bell wait so the wedding was
in Florence yes how many people were
there uh we had like 250 what everybody
paid to get themselves there all that
stuff yeah they did okay and I didn't
know when I planed this wedding I
specifically chose a destination because
well one my dad was dead so I wanted to
have like a new experience and two if I
had a wedding in Atlanta every [__]
sory sister that I hadn't talked to in
25 years was going to expect an invite
right and I was like I'm not doing that
dude 250 crazy in Florence but you don't
realize cuz obviously it's like 10 and
something you know 125 and then
everybody gets a guess so I was like
everybody gets a guess I didn't want
anybody if you're traveling all that way
you get a buddy um and then I didn't
think that many people were going to
come because it was a destination but
everybody was like [__] that it's Italy
let's go true that is that thing of like
[__] it we're go it's not a crazy flight
it's what seven hours or what it's not
like a 14 hour flight did you do a band
or a DJ so in Italy you really need to
do a DJ because there's nothing when I
interviewed a bunch of the different
bands it's like people with nobody knows
Toby Keith yeah nobody knows Toby Keith
they're like singing you know Kelly
Clarkson Since You've Been Gone In Like
A horrible Italian accent since you have
been but we had DJ Remo I want to give a
big shout out to DJ
Remo who was the best I had the best had
petamine forever he really did yeah yeah
shout out to Remo cocktail hour with or
deres absolutely okay pastor deres or on
the table uh Pastor deres first ask
person I can ask about Pastor der no we
had no bacon wrap scallops but we had
the I mean I had a full sh cute plate I
had a pasta station I had pizza it's
Italy Jesus but you have to realize my
wedding was [__] incredible it was
over the top I'll tell you right now if
you're going to judge me on anything you
look at my wedding photos that was the
classiest party that's ever been thrown
ever period I had the best wedding I've
never had someone challenge us like this
I dare you go [__] yourself judge me on
my wedding did you have a costume change
absolutely I knew let's go first of all
I'm a very attractive female why would I
not give you options all right she got
you there T-Bone yeah we had fireworks
though and you fireworks yeah what the
[__] but the something's not adding up
here the best part was we we did the
fireworks and we were we were making
this traditional Italian cake underneath
the fireworks and we were too close to
them so all the ash started raining down
and destroyed the cake and people were
like hit in the deck but the guy who did
my fireworks was like basically think
you got a fireworks guy yeah but he was
like the version like the Swamp People
version like see yeah there we go he had
like was missing a hand you know he was
the redneck guy from from the Tuscan
Hills what's the what's the traditional
uh Italian wedding cake what you have
what was it um what is it called AA F I
think I'm butchering it right now I'm
butchering it I'm so sorry to all my
Italian Heritage but it's it's layers of
like essentially kind of like a felo
dough like a thin dough and then you
cream and berries it's it was [__]
great oh that's awesome man yeah okay
let's talk about fume are you sure yeah
let's talk about fume [__] it why not
let's do it we'll do it live we're
talking about fume I love it baby that's
right gang let's be honest some habits
are really hard to break but now you
could take the bad out of the bad habit
fume is an Innovative device to get you
looking at your habits in a whole new
way instead of electronics fume is
completely natural instead of vapor fume
uses flavored Air instead of harmful
chemicals fume uses natural flavors what
you get to keep is that activity itself
with movable Parts magnets for fidgeting
fume helps you de-stress while you work
to break your habit uh-huh uh it's a
fantastic tool you can use it uh it
makes you change your perspective of
what you're doing you look at it a whole
new way and that's the best thing when
you're trying to break a new habit is
looking at it a different way sure it's
got an adjustable airflow dial with
awesome flavors to choose from ditching
a bad habit can be fun it ain't got to
be painstaking and annoying stop cold
turkey stopping something we all put off
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy and enjoyably even fun fume has
served over 100,000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to fume head to
tume.in use the code garbage to save 10%
off when you get the journey pack today
that's trium
f.com and use the code garbage to save
an additional 10% off your order today
do it gang K let's talk about dra Kings
out to the kings of the drift gang NBA
fans the wait is over basketball is back
in DraftKings an official Sports
spending partner of the NBA has an
unbeatable offer you ready for this Q
ball hit me new customers can score $200
instantly in bonus bets for throwing
down just $5 on the NBA make things a
little more exciting with DraftKings
parlays stirring things up can be a lot
of fun and DraftKings can help you do it
you want to make that boring game a
little more exciting get over over there
on the draftking yeah uh basketball is
more fun when you're in in on the action
download draftking Sportsbook app now
and use the code ay new customers can
get $200 in bonus bets instantly for
betting just $5 only on draftking
Sportsbook with code a
YG uh the crown is yours gambling
problems call 1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York you
can call
8778 Hope n or text Hope and Y in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
9777 7 or you can visit
ccpg dorg please play responsibly on
behalf of booill Casino and Resort
Kansas licensed partner Golden Nugget
Lake Charles Louisiana 21 and over age
verifies by jurisdiction void in Ontario
hosers bonus expire 168 hours after
issuing C sportsbook.com
draftkings.com basketball terms for
eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
when's the first time you had Nutella
you probably had Nutella all growing up
didn't you no I mean when did I first
have Nella I don't know uh probably when
I went abroad we we traveled abroad so
yeah probably when I went abroad Nella
didn't come to the states to like we
were in college I thought it was a
couple years ago I
know huh any turquoise jewelry uh yeah I
love a I love a turquoise moment you do
yeah I do yeah I do okay any turquoise
jewelry I'm [__] dying anyone in your
family pronounce the days of the week as
Monday Tuesday or Wednesday no
absolutely not okay anyone in your
family have a standalone hot tub oh [__]
no you guys got a pool at the house we
do salt
water imported from ity imported I got a
water guys the
pelo it's a bunch of limes floating
around yeah okay now the reason we built
the pool is because my dad who built the
pool your mom did or you guys did oh uh
my my dad did it the pool's been there
for a while my dad was a big southern
guy and he had like a knee replacement
they were like oh the pool will be good
so we built the pool and like he was
going to swim every day and he and I
both have eczema so we got salt water
cuz it's good for our skin okay we my
dad never did laps that's all I want to
say sure yeah sit there in his dunger is
there a hot tub in the pool not a hot
tub no I'm not a hot tub girl okay I
really don't love a hot tub I like a dry
sauna well that's the next classy thing
I want to build into my home is some
sort of dry infrared sauna but I don't
like a hot tub because when you have a
tiny urethra you get UTI frequently wait
what how get here oh well you know I
have a small pee hole so it's it's it's
sometimes I get UTI okay yeah all right
yeah do you have an outdoor blender an
outo no but we do have an outdoor bar we
have an oie pizza oven and a a Trager
Grill suck my dick yeah yeah you [__]
loser who the [__] needs a blender I'm
making zah over here I I got no I got no
no roommates in a cat I'm doing all
right yeah huh do you make your bed in
the morning um I try to okay I don't
have like a housekeeper coming to do it
if that's what we're pushing towards no
no no I mean you I me I mean no I'm I'm
kind of a mess my husband calls me like
hurricane Heather because again I'm on
the road I come home I'm home for 24
hours there's [__] everywhere but I'm
some energy to you're you're moving and
shaking exactly KingSize bed absolutely
okay yeah duvet yes and a nice quilt uh
yes and this is what's really great I
didn't take my husband's name and so all
of our monogram because we're Souther
I'm Southern all my monogram sheets have
my initials because that's tradition if
you don't take the other person's name
you take the woman's initials so
everything is hkm it's my initials on
everything that's let's go yeah it's a
power move did you say you put a you you
guys put a new bathroom in your room
right y his and her sinks yes okay
double vanity double vanity heated
floors uh not heated floors no cuz I'm
in Atlanta yeah yeah we're hot all the
time I run hot too my husband's a big
guy I'm a big gal we don't need we don't
need to be sweating more than we already
are separate bathroom and or separate
bath and shower or are they together um
well they're technically together but
also my husband has his own bathroom in
the other room like you know what I mean
really that's my that's my area who you
got a walk-in closet I presume
absolutely he got one too yeah two
Walkins yeah we're in a 7,000 foot home
what but we're also in Atlanta Georgia
we're not New York you know what I mean
like you can also 7 th that's a large
house it Ain bad man that ain't too bad
thanks Kyle you're flying up front
absolutely she's probably flying a
[__] plane this yeah get out of the
way you know who my grandfather was can
I be honest with you that is where I
spend my money in nice hotels and I and
I obviously like to fly up front because
I'm just I slept too [__] much or the
I get it I'm not doing it I I I was in
the back for too long Mama's up front
100% will you bring food on the plane
with you um I like a little snack pack
every once in a while you know I don't
want the blood sugar to dip because I'm
also I fly I'm loyal to Delta so how
many times can I have pistachios and vix
you know sure I like their gummy bears
their little veggie gummies those are
great they they wear off on you I love
them we're Delta people as well yeah
yeah Platinum no yeah I'm Platinum I'm
gold he's Platinum you got to be Diamond
I'm Diamond of course and I got to be
honest anybody who's listening from
Delta you know I deserve 360 and I would
really like for somebody to hand me
Delta 360 what's that it's like this
exclusive Club you got to get invited
into well I got to get in that now yeah
yeah you got to get diamond first
they're not even going to look at you
unless you get diamond F boo yeah come
on get your life together you're
gold yeah but I I'm I'm traveling every
weekend yeah so H if I didn't have
status I'd be doing it wrong sure you
like quail eggs oh yeah they're nice
favorite eggs benedict um I don't really
love eggs benedict really yeah I don't
love a hollay sauce huh yeah I like
creamy sauces but I don't love a hollay
I don't like a runny egg I like a nice
omelet what's a perfect breakfast for
you okay like a cheese grits cheese
grits some sort of biscuit and a like a
you know and and big thick Applewood
smoked bacon how you doing the eggs how
am I do scrambled scrambled with veggies
yeah with veggies yeah how many eggs you
knocking back three okay okay how do you
feel about biscuits and gravy um so
again not a big gravy gal I don't like
white gravy and I listen I want you're
breaking my heart I know I'm sorry but
it is thick I mean if you eat that I can
ask you to leave if you want me yeah
please get the [__] out of here it is
delicious but I can't eat it anymore cuz
then I'll [__] myself
immediately you know uh would you ever
get clothes for an event and then return
them oh yes I'm not a fool again I'm new
money the tags are still on this dress
right now okay yeah are they really no
this is my own clothing line suck my
dick everybody is it your own clothing
line no this is a collab I did with my
girlfriend shout out to show me your
Mumu yeah I Des she got her own line
yeah diversify I'm a classy broad to see
you on Shark Tank in a couple weeks yeah
for Real uh huh what's the Mayo
situation do you like uh Dukes only
Dukes okay not not no Miracle Whip no
Miracle Whip is not uh mayonnaise Dukes
is the only way to go shout out to the
Dukes she's classy what uh let's say
you're at a mall right it's the food
court it's dinner time it's about 5:30
30 what are you doing at a Mall food
court I got to be honest with you I'm
hitting a Chick-fil-A that's my go-to if
I'm in a food court I'm doing it now I
used to love growing up when you had
like the Mediterranean spot that was
called like Nature's beastro and they
always handed out like the honey honey
mustard chicken that's not Mediterranean
sure with the veggies yeah I'm not a
Panda Express cow if that's where we're
going it's not my thing okay and I love
Asian food but I don't like like I want
a real soup dumpling you know I want
authentic all right you a are you a food
EA you go to nice restaurants you treat
yourself nice I treat myself that's I
spend my money on food and first class
tickets Sushi like sushi love it o raw
oysters I oysters are like that's on my
death bed I want a Seafood Tower with
oysters she likes sea CRA claw yeah
again I'm from the south I an oyster and
a glass of you know like a Miller High
Life that's that's a good day to me okay
I threw you it is the champagne of beers
I got to say it is huh yeah these are
great I really this is really fun do you
know what the term BOGO is Bogo by buy
one get one yeah all right I'm a Max
anista I love a TJ Maxx I love a
Nordstrom Rack yeah we were just in
Nordstrom cuz I didn't bring a coat in
York because I was just down in Baton
Rouge and I was like the coat that they
picked out from me was like $1,400 I'm
not stupid I go to when I go to Europe
that's when I buy my expensive designer
bags I'm not buying it at the store on
Fifth Avenue why so I'm not going to get
the vat tax return are you out of your
mind that's 12% I want it back she's
skimming vat tax I don't even know what
that is buying clothes in Europe that's
crazy I don't think i' ever met anybody
bought clothes in Europe well I can't
buy clothes in Europe because they don't
make stuff that for you know they make
it for tiny people but I buy the buy the
nice hand I'm a European
6xl same if we came over to the house
right now and you offered us uh water
what would we be getting out of the tap
a brda a bottle okay this is where I'm a
real new money [__] let me tell you
what I got when I made my first check I
put in a crushed ice like Sonic ice like
the little tiny little pellets so I got
a really fancy ice this what I'm
thinking he p a crushed ice machine I
the really good Crush Sonic Ice yeah
type in Sonic Ice yeah oh like Sonic the
the the drive-thru you have that kind of
ice at your house yeah you can buy I
don't it's not branded from Sonic but
that's the kind of ice that that little
PE the BB ice the BB ice so it was like
5K and I bought that uh freezer so I had
that 5,000 on an ice machine that is the
trashiest classiest thing I've ever
heard in my life that's new money and
you're my hero there is nothing better
than having a nice iced tea or a nice
iced coffee with the good ice so if you
come to my house I mean I'm getting it
filtered out of the fridge you know okay
or I'll have we have a lot of peligrino
or perer I'm a sparkling uh sh also
shout out to a spin drift big spin drift
gal oh man yeah huh yeah what's the uh
appliances in the kitchen you got a sub
stainless steel we do have a subz
stainless steel but I'm trying to think
what's the uh what's it's not we don't
have like a wolf range but we have a ni
nice another but you know wolf that
means you're classy yeah come on it's
pretty good man hardwood floors you keep
the butter on the counter you keep it in
the fridge always keep it soft and then
I always have some Malden sea salt on
the side to put on top Malden is pain
stuff I got to box of that was late on
my rate my rent payment but are you
flossing every day uh yeah I got a water
pick off Amazon Prime day if you haven't
done the water pick it'll change your
life I can't get behind it I tried can't
do it I like it what's a toothpaste um
uh uh is it Marvis or Mavis Marvis it's
the Italian brand don't they do breakes
yeah Marvis it's either Marvis or Mavis
I can't remember Italian toothpaste yeah
I like it can I be honest with you the
the the crest and all that [__] makes my
mouth like I don't dries you out yeah
Italian toothpaste Marvis oh it looks
like you got it from an apothecary too
yeah Marvis toothpaste what's that going
for too T-Bones not expensive uh 13 13
for toothpaste where the hell you
getting that Italy no got have pay the
vat tax get it on Amazon Prime day whoa
Hy Munchy deodorant what are you using
um a brand called necessar it comes from
a volcano in Italy on no let me tell you
br it's classy if you if you're a woman
and you're listening to this podcast or
watching this right now and you're still
using aluminum four of them right so
love you ladies Michelle Lisa and
Tiff there is a tiff for sure you should
not be using anything with aluminum you
know better it gets into your lymph
nodes and that's why the rate of breast
cancer is high that's all that's my soap
box and I'm off okay I like it classy
PSA too safety
first man man you pee in the shower yeah
that's a natural thing okay yeah
honestly it does when it hits me the hot
water I'm also a woman you know what I
mean like we we don't get to pee out in
the wild as much as y'all get to so the
shower is a safe space to to pee I'll
give it to you I respect that you brush
your teeth in there yeah huh not every
not every day but if I'm in there and I
got to you know whip it out yeah I'll
the toothbrush isn't in there though
right oh no bring the toothbrush in and
then take it out no no it sits on my
it's charger it's electric of course I'm
not have a raw dog tooth do that well
they're they're animals you're not wrong
you're not wrong respect uh what' you
call the remote control uh a clicker ooh
clickers bad I know my mom's from Boston
clicker Heather where's the clicker or
the doohickey she's like where's the
thing of the doey doick Jesus Christ
pretty good H if you go to uh to CVS or
whatever and you make a purchase well
would use your debit card will you get
cash back um no not at CVS cuz that
always seems sketchy but I do use my I I
do put wrong I put put in my rewards
like I'm getting my rewards course I'll
give you that I'll give you that so
you're not a cash back girl no I'm not a
cash back girl no I go to Chase once a
week and I get out like 500 bucks cash
and that's what I do yeah because right
and shout out to my friend Tina who I'm
I haven't been to a chase this week and
I'm literally like hey I need 20 bucks
because here's the other thing I am
after working in Hospitality forever I'm
always like cash care breaking people
off probably a good Tipper I would
imagine I am a very good Tipper I I mean
even you could spit in my food and take
a dump on the table and I'm still like
oh 20% will you send anything back what
would be the what would be the the
reasons for that I mean if something's
undercooked like if you're giving me raw
chicken and I'm still so passive aggress
or not even passive I'm just passive
about it like I am so sorry I'll
apologize but this is um you know this
still has the feathers on it um okay uh
will you ask to change a table at a
restaurant um I will not my mother as
soon as we sit down ask to change the
table and she has never worked in a
restaurant and it is the B of my
existence I get that how you getting
your steak cooked um I like medium um I
don't understand how people do it black
and blue now I love a beef tartar I love
a beef Carpio but I like a medium I
really do and I I don't I I'm with I'm
right there with you because it could go
either way it's always going to be a
little undercooked and then when it
comes out sizzling you know what I mean
with the butter and the thing it's it's
perfect in the last 365 days have have
you eaten fried okra ABS I had fried
okra this weekend I was in Mississippi
how do you feel about the boiled peanut
I love a boiled peanut okay yeah I think
actually in New York you know everybody
has like the toasted pecans or whatever
the sugar pecans those smell better than
they taste but a boiled peanut on the
side of the road when you're driving to
Oxford Mississippi is a great treat yes
do you know cookout you know the place
cookout I love cookout at 4:00 a.m. I
get a cheese quesadilla and like a
milkshake yeah she's chees quesadilla
and a milkshake yeah cookouts unbel
I went there once when was at the
Laughing Skull Festival God yeah Place
blew my mind the hush puppies so good
takes a couple extra minutes but you're
waiting for the
quality it's all right I you know what I
do I wait for Quality there you go yeah
you have a you have a checkbook um I do
have checks but I don't know I'm I'm
isn't everything digital now for the
most part my mom knows where my
checkbook is so she has texted me today
I'm just going to cut a check so she's
just been signing checks herself from my
checkbook
you owe me that 300 I'll just write a
check any balloons or anything on the
checks no no straight a straight check I
respect it now I did my first debit card
was a Susan gcan card because it was
black and it just had a tiny little you
know the little pink ribon in the corner
um so I got that because I thought like
oh maybe people like at first glance
will think it's like a black AMX make it
till you make it baby yeah I was like 22
I'm like put pie of electrical tape over
that you'll be all right any of your
cards or debit cards have the activation
sticker still on them no no but my mom
does that my mom does not take the
activation sticker on cuz she doesn't
want if her wallet gets stolen she
doesn't want people to think that the
car will work yes Boston Robin man
that's awesome yeah that is some that is
some crazy logic right there I like it
well this clearly is we're not going to
try this the stickers on there what's
the what's the wallet what what uh what
brand are you rocking oh shout out to my
leather my leather gal Pini in Florence
Italy what what I got a I got a leather
gal I've brought her so much business sh
shout out to cilia she's the best um I
buy all my stuff from Pini in Florence
Italy man who are you yeah I'm a classy
broad you are a classy broad uh you wear
shoes in the house um yes and no growing
up we were absolutely not allowed to
wear shoes in the house but now I do
wear Sho your house you'll do whatever
freak you want yeah exactly you got a
Swiffer uh yeah and a wet Chet oo wet
you got a Roomba I got a Roomba but it
we don't do the Roomba I bought two my
French Bulldogs have destroyed it you
know what I love shout out chasing the
thing around it shout out the shark I
like the Shark vacuum you like the shark
and you know what when I went to Costco
I splurged I got a shark for every floor
of the house did you know I pegged you
for a for a Dyson gal I got a Dyson air
purifier but I like the shark uh vacuum
a lot wait you mean the Dyson the no
that's the yeah the the the one that you
leave in the room yeah hm you keep that
on when you when you go to bed at night
I do yeah ceiling fan in the room
absolutely I run hot you do M you go to
you guys go to sleep with the TV on um
my husband like falls asleep in like 3
seconds and it takes me like two and a
half hours to fall asleep so he'll fall
asleep with the TV on I'm usually on the
Tik toks giggling okay yeah are you
reading anything right now absolutely
not I don't have time to read and I know
that's a thing she goes up and down I
know people are always like what are you
reading you have time if you have time
to sit down with a book good luck to you
okay again I'm shaking my tits for cash
let me live you sleep on your side sleep
on your back sleep on my stomach sleep
your stomach yeah and I got big tits so
it's kind of hard but I'm I'm like this
like kind of on my side kind of on my
stomach really wao I don't think I ever
met anybody that's slept on their
stomach before you do a sleep mask or
earplugs or anything no sleep mask no
earplugs but I run hot um so I have this
thing so embarrassing um this thing
called the chili sleep pad and it
connects to what kind of looks like a
humidifier so it runs cool like air yeah
it runs cool air underneath me I did IVF
two years ago and after that my hormones
were all [__] up and then I just like
I I I'm sweating through this right now
you know me I'm like Cat Williams when
you see me come off stage I'm like Gat
Williams dabbing yourself yeah and I'm
in the same like pimp suit so you're
sleeping on so that thing yeah like this
kind of like this a little on the side a
little on the tummy Whoa man mhm sleep
with your socks on no absolutely not she
runs hot that's the first thing that
goes what are you nuts got but I will
tell you if you have trouble sleeping
put a little magnesium cream CU it's the
best way for your body to absorb it on
your feet put some socks on and you will
sleep better if you have socks on it's a
scientific fact so when I'm really
exhausted I'll do a little magnesium
spray on the feet the socks and then
halfway through the night I kick them
off yeah calculated lady yeah very
calcula who's doing the hair who's
cutting the hair oh shout out to Boh
Brit I knew this was gonna get a shout
out U my girl Brett she um is out of
Augusta Georgia so I got a hair team
that comes from Augusta Georgia and they
come do my hair in Atlanta in my kitchen
so I'm I'm real classic they come to you
they come to me yeah oh they do it all
that's all right they do miss Atlanta
miss Savannah they do they do the Real
Housewives of Atlanta so do they yeah
absolutely they do yeah come on now you
ever going to end up on that show you'd
be good no I won't um they haven't had a
white girl on there in a minute but no I
I don't want to do reality I got asked
to do the real house I was in New York
and I was like living in Atlanta and I'm
like I don't even live in New York
anymore but um no I soon as you do
reality any reality show you either get
divorced or you get audited by the IRS
and usually they go to jail yeah damn
yeah uhhuh do you like orina uh no I
like Fanta though okay you booze you
like a drink oh I love a drink what are
you drinking okay uh what don't I drink
my my favorite drink right now that's
really going to make me sound classy is
a chopan which is a potato based vodka
chopan slightly dirty martini blue Chi
stuffed olives I can also do just a
tequil on the Rocks I can do an
oldfashioned I can drink a Miller High
Life I drink everything so basically
you're the coolest person we've ever met
I read that as basically you're an
alcoholic but that's also alcoholic yeah
have you had a mint Jewel up recently I
love a mint Jewel up yes the Kentucky
Derby is phenomenal I love Kentucky
shout out to Kentucky you like the races
Kentucky um I've never been to the races
but yes I do love the races okay yeah
I've bet on the
races I mean I'm I think we I have
enough to render a decision yeah I mean
I think she's a I think I think I'm in
love with her to be honest with you
she's the class you are my type you look
similar to my husband and my father so
I'm I'm a little hot and bothered over
here man split his Seafood
down a I'm
in holy cow yeah I mean I'm I'm saying
100% class than that's where I'm at
there was a little bit dirt under the
fingernails early on I thought we had
her I thought we had her dead to right
yeah and then it just systematically
parents rag to Rich's story nice love
story She's Tight with the mom she's
[__] Europe Turks and caos 7,000 foot
house I thought Hilton Head was going to
be classy and then you hit us with Turks
and GEOS and you're flying down there
not to mention [__] Grandpa Jack yeah
hero that he is goddamn hero hat off to
him saved
lives yeah the Mayo the butter the water
pick maldon salt on top salt water pool
saltwater pool for the ezema for their
eczema it's a prescription pool it is
yeah the [__] Sonic ice machine that
I mean the house that's a that's a
Hillbilly's dream that's what that is
good ice at the crib good ice at the CRI
best ice at the crib mm yeah hether
McMahon 100% class buddy thank you I
really appreciate it but just so you
know I'm very approachable you know what
I mean she'll still slap the [__] out of
you I'll slap the [__] out of you but
I'll be wearing Old Navy when I do it so
everybody relax catcher at the cookout
drive-thru yeah what's the luggage by
the way what are you using luggage wise
um away sensible I like it okay lug a
away luggage can take a beating anybody
who carries around Louis Vuitton luggage
or anything like that is asking for
their [__] to get rifled through and
again my parents work for the Airlines
and they were like have the shittiest
luggage and a Way's great I love them
but like don't have yeah don't be flashy
with don't be flashy with your luggage
you're going to get your [__] stolen are
you stupid they go bag she's smart
T-Bone she's smart smart yeah gang
special is out on Netflix right now that
you have to check out the sun I never
had the very funny on tour right now
Heather McMahon everybody hey thanks for
having me this has been a real pleasure
you unbelievable congrats on everything
anything else you want the folks out
there to know you want to hit them I
mean just get your tickets at Heather
onto.com I love you I'm can't wait to
see the comments on this people going to
be like this is a rich [__] but I'm
going to tell you if you come to my
shows you'll have a good time it's
approachable for everybody love to hear
and if you're a single man I have a lot
of women in my audience so I always say
if you're single yeah if you're looking
to get laid come to a Heather McMahon
show the smartest plug has ever happened
on this show I'm telling you it is a
safe space for guys and I will often
like call guys out and and and I want
everybody to have a good time I'm a I I
I love to bring a love connection so
come to the shows and and you'll get
laid you're welcome go kiy what do you
got for him guys we're over the road uh
shows are selling out just out of the
four show in Chicago get tickets to that
uh it's a good time everything's
available at arug garbage.com gang we
love you and we'll see you next week
peace